let's talk to warren frye who attended
the parade with the seven
year old twins and his wife warren
really kind of you to talk to us today
how how are you feeling
uh it was very challenging to sleep last
night we had a big lightning storm as
well so
every time i heard a lightning strike it
sounded like a gunshot so
psychologically it's very challenging
but we're very lucky
we weren't hurt we only heard the shots
and we saw everybody run away
so when did you first realize that
something was wrong
uh as soon as
the crowd started to scatter it was a
bunch of families just sitting watching
everyone go by a nice little family
parade and all of a sudden people
started to move in a very unique
direction
and people started to say shooter tutor
run run run bang bang bang
and it would be very odd you know even
though it was closer to life fireworks
be going up in the middle of the day so
something was something was off and
everyone started to just run and go
frantic so it was very challenging
and how close were you to that gunfire
you could hear it obviously
yeah i'd hop a street away
so if i was two minutes later to the
event to the parade we might have been
sadly shot or hurt
so yes we're about a half and street
away
from the community
it it very well it was just outside a
local restaurant and you could also
coming from above and then they later
found out the shots actually were
and and you've got your seven-year-old
twins with you i mean did you
but my initial thought would have been
you know when you hear something like
that you just don't know which way to
run you don't know whether you're
running into danger or away from it do
you
uh we saw
and heard all the sounds coming above us
and ahead of us so we figured it was
best idea to run away and to get those
who can protect us to get into these the
situation meaning the police and
different police who were taking care of
the situation we saw people hiding
behind bins
we saw blood on the street it was a very
scary situation but we we thought that
it was best to run away and let the
first responders come in
and when did you feel safe where did you
go to
i went to my mother-in-law's house who
was about five minutes away and we
stayed there for about four or five
hours
because he was still on the loose nobody
knew where he was he was just described
as 18 to 20 year old white male which
could be a lot of people in the
community so we were scared and once we
knew that he was caught
then we went home and then late last
night my son woke up with a horrific
nightmare saying someone's killing me
someone's trying to kill me and he
started shaking so this nightmare is
just starting
yeah do you think this will change at
anything warren in terms of of the the
round the discourse about gun regulation
in america
i i see it more than just the gun
regulation this person could have had a
bomb this person had a gun i look at it
from those with neurological disorders
like myself i have a condition called
dyspraxia why did this person
who struggled who ended up dropping out
of high school who had problems in the
community not get to support and me and
my kids with dyspraxia are getting the
help within our ieps what made him do
this this is what we want to know as a
family is how we can make sure nobody
else feels so horrible they have to
shoot down our innocent victims
and the news that it was a local man
what impact does that does that have on
the community that it was somebody from
within your own community that was doing
this
very scary that it's it could be
homegrown it's also very fearful that
this child
now an adult in his 20s wasn't supported
why did he get to this point
what did they lack within our community
that we can help and improve so another
child who becomes a teen or adult
doesn't feel so angry that he has to
attack innocent people